et des machines bipaient inexplicablement
tandis que l'horloge sur le mur indiquait la tombée de la nuit.
L'horloge se situait au-dessus d'une porte
dans le champ de vision
de ma femme allongée dont les contractions s’intensifiaient.
Bien sûr, je n'ai jamais accouché -
(Rires)
mais elle m'a assuré que la dernière chose qu'une femme
qui va accoucher voudrait, c'est voir passer les secondes.
(Rires)
Architecte de formation, j'ai toujours été fasciné
de voir la façon dont les gens vivent le design autour d'eux.
Je crois que le design est comme la bande-son d'un film
qu'on entend sans y prêter attention.
Il nous envoie des messages inconscients à propos de comment se sentir
et à quoi s'attendre.
Cette pièce où nous étions semblait complètement inadéquate
avec le moment que nous étions en train de vivre :
accueillir un nouvel être humain,
notre fille, dans ce monde.
Une infirmière s'est tournée vers nous,
tout à coup, et nous a dit :
« J'aurais aimé devenir architecte
car j'aurais pu concevoir
ce type de pièce d'une bien meilleure façon. »
Je lui ai dit :
« Mais un architecte a bien conçu cette pièce. »
(Rires)
Malgré la joie immense qu'a apportée la naissance de notre fille,
encore aujourd'hui, ce que renvoyait cette pièce est resté gravé en nous.
Elle nous disait :
« Vous n'êtes pas chez vous,
vous êtes dans un lieu étranger. »
« Vous ne contrôlez rien.
Pas même la lumière. »
« Votre confort est tout simplement secondaire. »
Au mieux,
une pièce comme ça
pourrait être décrite ou rejetée comme terne.
Ou pire encore, comme indigne.
Et je l'utilise pour souligner qu'aucun d'entre nous,
où que ce soit dans le monde,
n'est à l'abri d'un mauvais design.
J'ai choisi l'architecture parce qu'il s'agissait
de créer des espaces pour que les gens vivent le mieux possible.
Pourtant, j'ai trouvé un métier largement déconnecté
des personnes qui sont directement concernées par son travail.
Je pense que c'est parce que l'architecture reste
un métier élitiste d'hommes blancs
qui ne semblent pas concernés
par certains des besoins les plus importants de ce monde
ou même par les besoins relativement simples d'une femme enceinte.
Les étudiants sont formés à l’école
en utilisant des projets très théoriques,
mais sans interaction réelle avec les gens ou les communautés.
Les diplômés s'engouffrent vers un chemin long, étroit
et impitoyable, qui les mène au diplôme.
Entretemps, la profession en sélectionne une poignée
par des programmes de prix incessants
qui se basent presque exclusivement sur l'esthétique des bâtiments,
plutôt que sur leur impact ou sur leur apport à la société.
Cela ne fait que renforcer une vision biaisée
de la responsabilité et du succès professionnel
mais ce n'est pas pour ça qu'autant de jeunes pleins d'espoir
font architecture.
Ce n'est pas pour ça que je l'ai fait.
Je croyais alors, même si je ne savais pas l'exprimer,
et je sais maintenant, que le design a une capacité unique de rendre digne.
Faire que les gens se sentent valorisés,
respectés,
honorés et vus.
J'aimerais que vous pensiez aux espaces où vous vivez.
Et je voudrais que vous pensiez aux émotions qu'ils génèrent.
Il y a des lieux qui nous rendent malheureux,
malades,
ou sans intérêt.
Ça peut être les espaces où vous travaillez,
où vous vous guérissez,
ou même où vous vivez.
Comment les concevoir tout en pensant à vous ?
C'est une question facile
à laquelle il est parfois difficile de répondre.
Nous sommes conditionnés à croire que nous n'avons aucun contrôle
sur les espaces où nous vivons, travaillons et jouons.
Et dans beaucoup de cas, c'est vrai.
Mais nous devrions.
Voici une question qui semblera stupide aux femmes qui regardent.
Avez-vous déjà fait
une queue exagérément longue pour aller aux toilettes ?
(Rires)
Ne vous êtes-vous pas dit : « Qu'est-ce qui ne va pas ? »
Et si la vraie question était :
« Quel est le problème des hommes qui ont conçu ces toilettes ? »
(Applaudissements)
Cela peut paraître futile,
mais cela représente un problème beaucoup plus sérieux.
Le monde actuel a littéralement été construit par des hommes
qui ont rarement pris le temps de comprendre
comment les gens différents d'eux
expérimentent leurs designs.
Une longue queue pour les toilettes semble un problème mineur.
Mais l'inverse est également vrai.
Un design bien pensé permet aux gens se sentir respectés
et vus.
J'en suis arrivé à croire que la dignité est au design
ce que la justice est à la loi
et la santé à la médecine.
Plus simplement,
les lieux que vous occupez doivent refléter votre valeur.
Durant les deux dernières années,
j'ai eu l'occasion d'interviewer plus de 100 personnes de tous les milieux
sur leur expérience du design.
Je voulais tester mon intuition selon laquelle
la dignité et le design sont intrinsèquement liés.
J'ai écouté Grégory,
un habitant de ce village de cottages
conçu spécialement pour les 50 sans-abris les plus chroniques de Dallas.
Gregory a vécu dans la rue,
se laissant porter de ville en ville, pendant plus de 30 ans.
Une grande coalition
d'agences de services sociaux,
de donateurs et de designers,
a créé ce lieu.
Chaque maison de 40 m² est joliment conçue
comme un domicile fixe.
Gregory a maintenant la clé
de la porte
de sa propre maison.
Il décrit la sensation de sécurité que cela lui apporte.
Une chose qu'il n'avait pas ressentie en trois décennies.
Quand il est arrivé avec un peu plus que les vêtements qu'il portait,
il a tout trouvé :
d'un grille-pain, une poêle, un four,
à une brosse à dents et du dentifrice qui l'attendaient.
Il l'a décrit simplement
comme le paradis.
De l'autre côté du globe,
j'ai écouté Antoinette,
la directrice d'un centre communautaire de formation pour les femmes,
dans la campagne rwandaise.
Des centaines de femmes fréquentent ce centre quotidiennement
pour acquérir des compétences,
être en communauté,
et continuer à reconstruire leur vie
après la guerre civile qu'a connue le pays.
Ces femmes ont littéralement pressé
les 500 000 briques
qui servent à la construction des 17 salles de classe comme celle-ci.
Antoinette m'a dit :
« Tout le monde en est si fier. »
Et de retour ici aux États-Unis,
j'ai écouté Monika,
la directrice d'une clinique gratuite
qui s'occupe principalement les non-assurés de l'Arkansas.
Monika adore me dire que les docteurs,
qui font du bénévolat à sa clinique,
lui disent quotidiennement
qu'ils n'ont jamais travaillé dans un endroit si beau et lumineux.
Monika croit
que même les personnes pauvres
méritent des soins de santé de qualité.
De plus,
elle pense qu'ils méritent de recevoir ces soins
dans un environnement digne.
Ces personnes sont de précieux ambassadeurs du design
et pourtant, ils sont clairement absents du discours architectural.
De même, les personnes qui pourraient le plus bénéficier d'un bon design
sont souvent celles qui n'y ont pas accès.
Votre cousin, un vétéran sans-abri,
votre grand-mère ou grand-père
qui habite dans une maison où la cuisine ne lui est plus accessible,
votre sœur en fauteuil roulant
dans une banlieue planifiée sans trottoirs.
Si le design de qualité est uniquement le privilège de quelques-uns,
à quoi bon ?
Le temps est venu pour les designers de changer cela
en dédiant leur travail au bien public,
en suivant l'exemple d'entreprises
comme Orkidstudio,
Studio Gang,
et MASS Design Group.
Leurs clients
sont des orphelins au Kenya,
des enfants adoptés à Chicago,
et des femmes enceintes au Malawi.
Leur travail se fonde sur le principe
que tout le monde mérite un design de qualité.
Consacrer plus de temps au bien public
créera non seulement un design qui rend digne,
mais donnera aussi de la dignité à la pratique du design.
Non seulement cela diversifiera la clientèle du design,
mais cela créera aussi de nouvelles et multiples formes de design
pour le monde.
Maintenant, pour y arriver,
chers amis architectes et designers, et surtout mes camarades blancs,
nous devons simultanément et de manière significative, nous diversifier.
Si nous voulons que le public croie que le design s'adresse à eux
et à tout le monde.
Aujourd'hui, à peine 15%
des architectes diplômés aux États-Unis sont des femmes.
Et un pourcentage encore plus petit sont des personnes de couleur.
D'autres professions, comme droit ou médecine,
ont fait des progrès considérables dans ces domaines cruciaux.
Comment pourrait notre environnement -
nos maisons, nos hôpitaux, nos écoles, nos espaces publics -
être conçu différemment,
si des femmes
et personnes de couleur concevaient ces plans ?
Ce n'est pas une question de « si »,
mais dans quelle mesure
nos bâtiments, nos paysages,
nos villes, nos campagnes
sont moins beaux, moins fonctionnels,
moins équitables et moins dignes,
que si une femme ou une personne de couleur les avaient créés.
Comme Winston Churchill l'a si bien formulé en 1943
appelant à la reconstruction
du Parlement de Londres qui avait été détruit :
« Nous façonnons nos édifices, et après, ce sont eux qui nous façonnent. »
La bonne nouvelle est que nous pouvons changer notre façon de construire
et pour qui nous construisons.
Devenons ce professionnel de la santé au Rwanda,
ou cette femme enceinte et ce nouveau papa si nerveux aux États-Unis.
Nous pouvons le faire en renouvelant l'architecture
pour la santé, la sécurité et le bien-être du public.
Il y aura un retour sur investissement.
Parce que lorsque vous voyez ce dont le design est capable,
vous ne pouvez l'ignorer.
Et lorsque vous avez goûté à la dignité,
vous ne pouvez plus accepter moins.
Ils deviennent une partie de votre possible.
Une de mes partenaires de conversation préférés est ma grand-mère de 90 ans,
Audrey Gorwitz, d'Oshkosh, dans le Wisconsin.
Après une de nos conversations sur le design,
elle m'a écrit une lettre.
Elle disait : « Cher Johnny,
l'autre jour, au cabinet de mon docteur, j'ai pensé
comme c'était déprimant,
de la couleur du mur, jusqu'à celle du tapis.
(Rires)
Je vais devoir appeler pour savoir
qui est responsable de la morosité de cet endroit. »
(Rires)
Dans la même lettre, elle disait :
« J'ai parlé avec le responsable,
et il m'a dit qu'il appréciait que quelqu'un l'appelle.
Le cabinet de mon docteur va bientôt être rénové. »
(Rires)
Elle l'a signée en disant :
« C'est toujours bien de donner son opinion
si c'est fait poliment. »
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
J'adore ma grand-mère.
(Rires)
Comme ma grand-mère Audrey,
vous méritez un bon design.
Car lorsque les lieux bien conçus
ne se limitent pas à une question de goût ou d'esthétique,
ils façonnent vraiment nos idées sur qui nous sommes dans le monde
et ce que nous méritons.
C'est l'essence même de la dignité.
Et l'opportunité et la responsabilité du design
pour le bien
et pour tous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements).